what guarantees
um the life of states in a turbulent
World which is often cruel well you know
for some people on the left they think
that if you're moral and if you were
put up a nice facade to the world a
compliant facade then history will
protect you um
in fact they often quote Martin Luther
King who said that
the Ark of History bends towards Justice
maybe so but it is a very brittle Arc
and it could break under the pounding of
the darkest forces the totalitarian
dictatorial and uh and ideological
forces that are opposed to the very idea
of freedom and Justice so and history
doesn't favor morality it favors
Scranton
how do you balance some of the the
tensions between the the secular people
and the more religious people as someone
that's going to be prime minister for
everybody you've obviously done this a
couple times before uh obviously very
successfully but that that's one of the
the sort of fissures in Israeli Society
uh what you do in any uh democracy is
you compromise you make compromises
there are things you don't compromise
about on Israel's existence on security
I don't compromise and if I have to
stand up and go to a joint session of
Congress uh to challenge
um a person I respected but disagreed
with the President Obama uh he wanted to
pass this uh and did actually this uh
dangerous Iran nuclear deal which would
pave Iraq's path with gold to a nuclear
Arsenal well I thought I had no choice I
have to go and take a stand and gave a
speech there which I described in detail
uh so there are things you don't
compromise about but in the life and
political life and democracies that's
what you constantly do you either come
to an agreement with the opposing views
and if you don't come to an agreement
you bring it to uh to the vote uh and
often you
um you come to an agreement by arriving
at some kind of balance between opposing
views and that's being done every day
you do it in the American Congress you
do it in the Israeli knessel
so as someone that's uh you're you're
basically the same age as the country
within within a couple years uh and you
you were born in a time when you know
the country was trying to come together
was obviously not powerful a couple
couple Miracles basically to even come
into existence as a nation versus now
where there's a military might and an
economic power that you're talking about
how different is that for the Israeli
psyche or even just even just for you as
the leader of the country knowing what
the country was 50 years ago compared to
where it's at in 2022
well
you know I describe the roots of my
views and it's very much influenced by
my father was a great historian of the
Jewish people but what he taught me was
that there is no finality in the life of
Nations nations of combinations of God
and the Jewish people are perhaps unique
in the fact that having lost our country
having lost our state having been
dispersed to the Far Corners of the
earth we actually came back and
reconstituted our national life uh in in
our home and our tiny Homeland but our
homeland and the fact that we did that
was I would say the uh the mission of
restoring Jewish nationhood and Jewish
Independence uh in the land of Israel
was the task that informed my
grandfather
uh and my father uh in founding and
helping found the state the test that uh
that I inherited was to secure the
future the the the prosperity and
especially the security and permanence
of this state uh because it's not
guaranteed well I what guarantees what
guarantees
um the life of states in a turbulent
world
which is often cruel well you know for
some people uh on the left they think
that if you're moral and if you were put
up a nice facade to the world a
compliant facade then history will
protect you
in fact they often quote Martin Luther
King who said that
the Ark of History bends towards Justice
maybe so but it is a very brittle Arc
and it could break under the pounding of
the darkest forces the totalitarian
dictatorial and ideological forces that
are opposed to the very idea of freedom
and justice so and history doesn't favor
morality it favors strategy that's what
it does that's why Jameson could conquer
conquer the world and all his uh you
know and hold down that Empire could
hold on for a century could an enormous
subjugation the Romans whatever you
think of them held it for many many more
centuries who just sheer power sheer
coercion and power and there's a
guarantee that our free civilization
does history guarantee that our free
civilization would triumph over
totalitarian forces and the answer is
categorically not if they can amass
greater economic military and political
power especially economic and military
power and they'll overcome you if you
don't have enough counter prevailing
Force Israel being a tiny country had to
be enormously more powerful given that
it was surrounded at first by hundreds
of millions of Arabs who wanted to
destroy it uh and Lately by about 100
million Iranians who don't want to
destroy it but are governed by these
theological Thugs who do and openly
clear death to Israel and by the way
death to America too but they're
building atomic bombs that's what they
seek to do to destroy Israel so you need
to be very very strong I devoted my life
as I described in my book to uh Empower
Israel not to not to subjugate others
but to defend itself from others and to
make sure that nobody could destroy the
one and only Jewish State once it was
reconstituted after thousands of years
the one thing that and all Israelis
understood that they understood that we
have to have a strong Army the first
Prime Minister David benguel invested an
enormous effort to build such an army
but I came to the conclusion that it
couldn't be sustained
it couldn't be sustained because F-35
fighter aircraft submarines drones cyber
intelligence and so on they have one
common quality they cost money a lot of
money and if you have a socialist
economy you're not going to be able to
pay for defense typically the way
Israelis thought about it well the
government will produce the money how
will they produce the money tax the rich
tax the rich well they're not first of
all they're not enough rich people in a
socialist economy and secondly those who
are will move to other places when you
over tax them I came with a radical idea
which I described in my book that
there's a thing called free markets
capitalism
and that's the way we generate both a
better life for our people a higher
income a higher distribution of income
compared to the uh what the Socialist
leading people were thinking but also it
gives us the wherewithal to fund our
military and therefore I initiated uh a
pre-market revolution in Israel that
made Israel into this Juggernaut this
pre-market Juggernaut of the Innovation
nation that can compete with any country
in the world that in fact does uh and
that changed Israel it gave it the
economic power to have to have military
power and the combination of the two
gave us diplomatic power and that is
what can guarantee our future not
forever
I don't know of anything that protects
you forever but for the coming decades
and that's what I intend to to nurture
further in the in the coming years and
my next 10 years prime minister if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
international issues instead of non-stop
yelling check out our International
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell